e
what I got
okay it's time no you're okay yeah there
you
go it being 10:00 we'll call a fiscal
committee meeting to order for Friday
March
15th and we have a
quorum I'll entertain motions to adopt
the minutes Some
Mo motion by Senator gray second
by Senator Enis to adopt oh wait a
minute you weren't here we take a second
second for Senator Dallas Sandro we'll
give it to senator dalland
to adopt the minutes any any uh changes
or Corrections seeing none you're ready
for yes who's in right over here I know
who he is but oh he's replacing
Brad he's looking for his his call
sheet I know who he is that's what all
right
replacing no further Corrections or
additions all in favor say I I oppose no
the minutes are adopted there's no old
there's no old items the uh consent
calendar just your extends from tab
three through tab eight and I've had
requests to remove the following items
from the consent calendar under tab six
item
24078 by Senator
burdel uh item 2482
by representative Edwards under Tab
8 item
2488 by Senator
birdell and items
2492 and
24094 by representative
Edwards is there are there any other
items to be removed by the
members seeing none I'll move to approve
as amended all right Senator gray moves
to adopt the consent calendar with those
f with the exceptions so noted second
second by representative Edwards further
additions or Corrections seeing none
ready for the question all in favor of
adopting the rest of the consent
calendar say I I oppose no the rest of
the consent calender is adopted so now
we'll move to AB six to
2478 Department of
Agriculture and I believe the
commissioner is
here
all right he's on his
way all
right all right commissioner
Jasper we're moving to
24078 the item that you had in
here relative to Pest Management Senator
bird cells recognize for
question thank you Mr chair thank you
you commissioner for taking my question
um more more on the if this is more of a
question from the fiscal item that we
passed last month and um I had spoken
with you about it last night um what
fiscal passed back in um
March um the qualifiers in there were um
um principally shall be principally
located in New Hampshire the events for
releas relief is sought to must have
occurred through New Hampshire borders
have been in operation since at least
January 1st of 2022 and experien a loss
of gross receipts from 22 to 23 now when
the program came out um there is an
additional eligibility criteria which
you added to that was 50% of Nest net
Farm loss can you explain why you
changed that
criteria so to be clear we did not
change the
criteria so even and I'll be glad to sit
down with anyone to explain this but all
along even in Senator ennis's Bill um
that this really morphed into there was
criteria because Farms lose money all
the time in my own business as a
landlord my net receipts go up and down
depending on how many tenants I have in
a building
so we wanted to make sure that in order
to award money it wasn't just that
people had a had these had lost money it
was you had to have your receipts down
you had to have all these things these
are the things that get you in the
door I believe that you New Hampshire
has always been clear we don't pay money
to people who still had a
profit and if you go through any of the
testimony even on the bill it was about
Devastation it was about people were
really hurt well if you're still making
money then obviously you are not in a
situation where you're going to close
your your doors
so the bill and and what we always
intended to do was pay to people who
lost and this document is on our web
website it was posted March 1st and in
it it's very clear starting March 1st
eligible Farmers eligible Farmers that's
based on the
criteria can apply for rewards intended
to account for 50% of net Farm loss so
in in my
mind everything we've done right from
the beginning was to help farmers who
lost money in their operations what I'm
now hearing from people is well it
simply if you had a decrease in your
net
income regardless of whether you were
profitable or not we're going to give
you money I that's foreign to me and so
perhaps that's why I never even gave
that a consideration that we were going
to be paying people just based on a
decrease in income now there have been
questions about what if somebody sent
sold off assets to be able to stay in
business there's a box 19 on the form
for an explanation if somebody was in
doing something that was outside of the
normal operations we will look at that
and certainly if somebody says I had to
sell equipment because otherwise I was
going to lose the farm we will take that
into consideration and make an award
based on those conditions and that's to
everybody we've said put in box 19 the
things outside of the norm so we can
consider that because I understand that
it's more than just profit and loss you
know I've been in in business my whole
life and I understand these things
things
so followup follow up so I may not dis I
may not disagree with you however I
still feel that you changed the criteria
from to a 50% net loss versus gross
profits could you have not at least
defined gross profits as that so they
they would know because when we put um
put this
through um I know that when it was
testified the state based their 16
million of loss um loss crops and we
based that 16 million we cut that in
half to give the um Farmers 8 million
based on crops
lost and this doesn't
match
so and I respect that this is not the
bill um this is a you know different
program but I guess again in my
mind if you're going to
lose you know your crops it's going to
result in a net loss and so yes I think
that there is some reasonable confusion
with this but this is not an entitlement
program either this is a program
designed to help people who are in a
devastating situation and I think for
most Farms um if they lost lost that
much of the crop it's going to result in
a pretty substantial net loss and and
frankly in New Hampshire we expect
people to Pivot and so if they were able
to recover some of that income through
other things that's that's great and
they did all right but many of them
would still have a net loss um so I I'm
not sure exactly what we can do now to
to change our message I have to tell you
quite honestly I have not had one single
call other than from the governor about
this and he called me because people are
calling him people are calling you what
nobody is doing is calling me that is
very
troubling that we're not getting those
calls directly I had one email that went
to director Marshall he forwarded it to
me I responded and that farmer did not
respond to me but I've heard that he's
been complaining to others about my
response without responding in to me so
there have been very few things that
have frustrated me um in my time in
conquered more than this because of the
lack of communications did you pay out
any money under this program we had two
we tried uh three was it two or three we
tried to get on as aate agenda for this
Wednesday um but we have have not uh we
didn't make it through GNC with those
yet most so you saw very few
applications early on as we expected
because this is tax season and for the
large op operations it's going to take
them quite a bit of time to get their
numbers together to work with their
accountant some of them will not have
their federal income taxes done I mean
some businesses like my business uh my
family business we actually don't close
out till March 31st but you can get an
ass assess yeah you can you can get a
document from your accountant attesting
to the fact that um this this is the uh
the facts so we're we're making
allowances for all of those things
further question Senator bdel and I
appreciate what you're saying
commissioner however if you look at the
eligible the
eligibility um you say it's not the
we're not talking about the bill but you
use the identical eligibility in the
bill as in your
qualifiers in in Senator if you look on
our eligibility page we are using all
the same eligibility but I would I would
call to your attention if we want to try
to compare apples to oranges which I
think it is looking at the crop loss the
the bill that Senator Enis sponsored if
you go down on uh page two I believe it
is there's all the eligibility and then
it then under the awards under the
emergency crop relief operation shall
have the following requirement no entity
shall receive more than 50% of gross
losses and it doesn't that doesn't match
the language that is in the criteria
which is a reduction in income we now
move into here's what gets you in the
door you have to have a reduction of
income and then you have to have a loss
one's an eligibility the other is the
actual
criteria on which the award is based and
we were consistent with that although we
don't have we're going on the Assumption
of 50% we don't have that restriction in
the actual program um we may revisit
that later depending on the awards we
have no idea you know what the numbers
are going to be um and so you know I I'm
proud of the program we put up out I am
sorry that there is confusion but in you
know in my
mind um we never just pay out money
because somebody had a reduction in in
income we pay out we help people when
they have experienced a loss to their
their total operation and and that's
where the confusion arose um I've gone
through all the testimony and there's
nothing specific to people thinking they
were going to get money based on a
simply
um a loss of Revenue nor is there
anything specific to saying they thought
they were going to it was based on a
bottom line loss so yeah there's
confusion back and and forth but again
this is this is not a guarantee none of
this is a guarantee and the fiscal note
that came before you said that um I can
read the language exactly that the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food will establish guidance and
application process based on the
following criteria for applicants with
approval by the governor and Council and
our whole application process did go
through that process was approved and
and that's what we came up with so I'm
I'm sorry we tried to move this as
quickly as we could because look at the
weather I think I heard peepers last
night um people are going to be looking
to get um crop in the ground they're
going to be needing that I know people
have got h2a workers coming in very soon
our whole idea uh was is to get the
money out to those who are in desperate
need of cash not just gee wouldn't it be
nice to give people money because they
experienced a decrease in their revenue
I guess page one criteria should have
been a bit
more explicit so they didn't oh good I'm
going to get the money and then go on
and not pay as much attention as they
build out the rest of it so Mr chairman
as always hindsight is 2020 U but I'm
glad to sit down with any member of the
legislature go over this um but this to
for us to do anything other than what we
put in the process would put a stop to
this whole program and have to go um
back through the process again uh and
frankly you know as I I said to the
governor how many people have actually
called I know nobody's called me so are
we talking about a very vocal minority I
think perhaps we are and I guess the
good news is the catastrophic losses
weren't as catastrophe as we thought if
nobody's really lost the farm over this
well I think there are a couple that are
probably are on the edge um but they
haven't got their applications in
because in some cases they've got to go
back to the previous owners they've got
to do a lot of work with their
accountants to get to us I mean we're
only open this is only the second week
it's been
open so thank you we're doing the best
best we can and right now uh it's very
frustrating Senator bdel thank you Mr
chair and I understand you say you
haven't heard from the um anyone except
for that one email but I know that um
someone from your office was in the
meeting when the program was announced
and an individual did get up and speak
about how he was re bured only
$4,900 or authorized $4,900 when in
reality his total loss was $15 but I
still go back to the fact
that we authorized gross
profits versus changing it to net
profits and if you wanted to make it net
then maybe there should have been in the
program a definition of what gross
profits were because that's what this
fiscal committee passed and I feel I
feel like it was changed without even
Consulting anyone on the fiscal
committee and the the farmers yes
they're up in an uproar about this
however they were under a different
understanding and we needed to get that
word
out I I appreciate that Senator to begin
in in what you actually passed it only
talks about the CR
criteria and and it and the only thing
is the
eligibility experienced a loss of gross
receipts as as the foot in the door the
rest was left up to us to to develop
which is consistent with the language in
the bill which did not pass and which
you know we were not wetted to because
it was not a bill that passed this was
the replacement of it but trying to be
respectful of what was done we tried to
mirror that in working with all all
party I again I mean I would be
absolutely opposed to paying money to
Farms that were profitable in the case
of the farm that you um referenced
looking at those those numbers that
person yes has has had
extraordinarily good returns over the
years I somewhat shocked by what a high
percentage his return is
um but he's had very good years for for
a long time and had a small loss this
year we gave him allowances he had a um
higher
depreciation um than normal this year so
we averaged that that was part of that
and gave a 15% increase to that we gave
a credit towards up to
5% um of his grosser receipts towards
Labor uh and yeah it still didn't amount
to to much but this is not this is not a
farm that is on on the brink um you know
and you are certainly welcome to say we
just want to give out money to people
even if they're making a profit if
that's the message from the legislature
that's your
prerogative that's not what I ever
understood any of this to be um so While
others may be confused and misunder I
certainly misunderstood if the intent
was just hey you get a a drop in your
income we're going to make up half of
the difference that's foreign to
me further one final point in the
explanation on the um item it says um
Department of agricultureal markets and
food will establish guidance and Grant
application process it doesn't say
change the process or change the
guidance and in regards to that IND
individual um he lost all of his Apple
crops and had to go out and purchase for
$225,000 additional Apples because he
had no apples so he did
have so some expenses that I don't think
were taken into consideration well those
expenses if he did not put those on his
schedule F that's not my my fault that
was a legitimate expense and I've talked
to many people who have um had the same
experience they went out purchased
apples made a small Pro process on that
up profit on those
apples but nonetheless it contributed to
the overall farm income you certainly if
the fiscal committee believes that I
misled them in in this note then you
know we'll have to stop the pro the
program and start over again um if
because it was not our intent to mislead
you it was our intent
to um to give you the criteria and say
would go forward with a program but I
I'll be glad to sit down with anybody if
there are any further questions but
ultimately you
know this program is based on your
approval and I respect the fact that if
you believe I misled you then we need to
deal with
that representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair thank you uh Mr commissioner uh as
I'm listening to this it I'm thinking in
background um what sort of affirmative
efforts is the department making to get
the word out to potentially uh needy
farmers are we are we taking an
affirmative stance towards pushing the
information we are through all of the
the organizations out there um NOA New
Hampshire Farm Bureau buau certainly the
work weekly Market Bulletin um the Press
has covered this I I doubt that there is
any Farm of any significant size in the
state um who isn't aware of it we've
been to the just last week to the two
major commodity groups the fruit and
vegetable Growers the um tree fruit um
Berry and vegetables so those commodity
groups are well aware it they're pushing
it out there we have been communicating
um to the best of our ability and I
really don't think that there's uh there
are too many people hiding under a rock
at this point who are not aware of this
thank you Mr thank you for the answer
you Senator
agree uh thank you
um when you characterize just giving
them money in in your statement
um I would have rather seen you
characterize that as we want to keep
people in the farming business you know
the small guy you know and and the big
guy uh and that you know looking at the
losses um you know like if the program
said uh if you received 10% of your
income from a farming effort in before
and that 10% was cut to nothing uh
that's different than looking at it uh
but certainly we don't want to be
perceived as you know giving money to
those who don't need it like we were
several times during the covid money uh
would you like to comment on on those
well sometimes
my my uh thoughts are not as uh as
politically correct perhaps as as they
should be and I and I verbalize them and
uh that's probably not to the benefit of
anyone but you know I you have the
benefit of hearing what what I'm
thinking whether that's uh the best
thing or not but I in anything we've put
out there we have always talked about
the fact that we want to help those who
need are in need 30,000 is a pretty low
number um because we were looking at
who's you know if if you're looking at
30,000 and you're looking at an average
business you know a 10% profit margin is
pretty good so we said all right that
would net somebody
$3,000 probably not life or death and at
what point we've done this really
without taking money for the Department
if you open this up to literally then
thousands of people at a small amount
we're going to be taking money away from
those who truly need it we spent an hour
on the on a zoom call yesterday with NOA
New Hampshire talking about that very
issue about those who who have
application have Farms of under
30,000 um they're important all of those
Farms are very important to New
Hampshire but in terms of a
disaster they're not likely to be put
under out of business but what I did
offer to them was say all right ask a
few Farms to put in those applications
even though they know they're not going
to be eligible at this point we'll look
at that we'll consider that and see if
we don't get to the full 8 million
should we then
come back and say all right let's let's
change that criteria we did that a few
years ago with the covid funds the and
because again we want to make sure that
we get as much money to those who are
making a living at it as possible when
there's money left over if the
government the powers that be feel that
it's appropriate to to spread that out
to some others who who got hurt but
aren't going out of business I'm
certainly happy to do this but you know
uh it's it's got to be narrow to start
with because it's pretty much josing
myself in one person from Cooperative
Extension who has been authorized to
assist with us it's not his full-time
job to do this if you open that up
immediately to everybody who had any
income from farming uh would' be
December before we got money out the
door um so everybody wants wants more
and I and I get that but we just we
can't make everybody happy I said to
Josh when we opened this program up I
said you watch no good deed goes
unpunished I'm going to have more people
mad at me that are going to be happy
with he said Oh no you're not and I said
oh yes I am and here we are
today Senator rosenal Mr chairman
commissioner following up on your
comment about if we don't spend and the
whole 8 million will have to go back
we're coming up on the deadline in a few
months for encumbering these funds my
understanding is that the $8 million was
arrived at by saying that was 50% of
crop losses so by narrowing the
criteria it seems like you're probably
not going to get the whole 8 million out
the door to Farms that have lost money
and my concern is that we leave this
money unspent when our intent at least
in the Senate was to go through fiscal
as a way to be quicker than going
through the legislative process I I
still believe that to be true and
commissioner Caswell is is sitting
behind me um and I believe that we
really have till the end of this
calendar year so if we get to May 15th
we can pivot again very quickly if that
is the wish uh of everyone involved
whereas a bill in all likelihood we
wouldn't have even started that process
until um late June early July so I
believe there is plenty of time we can
move quickly and efficiently which we
have have done here you know it's
obviously um ruffled some some feathers
along the way and you know as always
could Communications have been better in
hindsight yes it just in my mind there
was never any question that this was
about a loss to the farming operation
that we were that's all we were looking
at in my mind and I apologize for that
and there was never communication from
anybody saying are you talking about
simply l of Revenue or are you talking
about loss um on the bottom
line that didn't happen and I and I
apologize Mr chair further questions can
we we'd like to
caucus all right five minute
caucus all right we'll be in recess for
five minutes and we'll come back finally
to item
78 would you like us to stay here while
you
caucus SE yeah do any of us want a
caucus on the house
side we happy with
support yeah I think he's he's done what
is fiscally
feasible did you have any conversation
with me
yes
e
like
for
I declare the recess over we'll return
to item
24078 Senator gray move to pass the item
Senator gray moves Senator dallesandro
seconds to pass item
24078 further discussion seeing none
you're ready for the question all in
favor say I I oppose no
no wish to be
recorded all right nine to nine to one
motion is adopted moving on thank you
moving on to the next item
removed which would be 2482 on the same
tab Health and Human
Services see we have director white with
US senator Edwards is recognize for a
question on item
2482 uh thank thank you um Mr chair and
um welcome uh Mr White I I I just have a
basic contract question here I I see
that DUIs and King have done all the
surveying have determined the issues
that need to be resolved so I'm just I'm
just curious from a Contracting
perspective you know a do we uh expect
them to want to bid on doing the work
and and and B if if they do compete on
this contract is there anything in the
selection criteria that would um
have us U consider more
strongly the folks that have not worked
on the survey I I'm I'm talking about
competitive disadvantages here sure um
good afternoon members of the committee
Nathan white Chief Financial Officer of
the Department of Health and Human
Services the item before you um just for
everyone's uh context uh back during the
capital budget process of 2023 uh the
department had come forward with a
request to replace the Wastewater system
at Glen Cliff home um the total cost is
$1.8 million These funds are a grant
from the the Department of Environmental
Services to pay for the difference just
to kind of level Set uh relative to the
competitive bidding process um the
Department of Public Works under RSA 21i
is uh required to um put forward and
they're responsible for all bidding when
it comes to construction projects so I
can assume that there would be no
special provision or no special
Advantage because that'd be in violation
of RSA 21 uh
G37 uh which were and and 21i as well
which requires that objective criteria
be known to all parties so I would not
expect that there would be any advantage
given there um I don't know if um
where's uh commissioner Arling house I
don't know if you'd like him to comment
further thank you and as he's
approaching I i' just point out my
general thought here and that is
uh the the the the person doing the
survey tends to have a a competitive
Advantage because they know more about
the project and I I'm I'm I just want to
make sure we're maintaining a
competitive
environment uh Charlie Arling house to
uh Department of administrative Services
design firms don't bid on the final
contract
period for the reason you just said
Thank
you any further questions on item 248
two Senator dalland moves to adopt
seconded by Senator gray further
discussion seeing none are you ready for
the question all in favor say I I oppose
no that item is adopted we'll move on to
Tab
8 and item 88 again Department of
Agriculture markets and food move to
table
s all right motion to
that Senator birdell seconded by Senator
gray to table item
24088 further discussion seeing none
you're ready for the excuse me Mr
chairman I know you're not supposed to
ask questions when as a move the table
I'm just
curious why there was any discussion
before a motion to table was
offered
if uh Senator birdell will remove her
motion for a minute and certainly I will
speak to it
she's items motions withdrawn
temporarily um certainly there is uh uh
some things about the meat packing I've
been on several committees that have uh
Gone along with that uh it is a farm
related issue where they would be making
profits it's most closely Rel related to
the issue that we were discussing before
uh and we want to have further
discussion on that before we pass this
item and I will renew the motion to
table
now okay back to the item to table it's
disgusting all
right
second all right motion to table all in
favor say I I oppose no no how many know
four
NOS all right six to four tabling item
is
adopted all right moving on to the next
item on my
list
24092 also in this
tab
Health and Human
Services New Hampshire hospital
again
um security
upgrades representative Edwards is
recognized uh thank you Mr chair and and
and thanks again uh for considering my
question I I I just um I think this is
Well written but it just leaves me
curious uh We've appropriated um um
money for the forensic hospital and the
forensic Hospital uh By Design had to
have some kind of a secure vestibule to
get in and now we're we're we're saying
that we need to upgrade um the New
Hampshire hospital and I've seen it and
so I I I understand the need what I what
I don't really understand is if if is
how the money is working if we've
already appropriated money for the
forensic hospitals
vestule why you know why do we need
another 2.6 million this this seems to
me like a component of the forensic
project that could be morphed to help
the New Hampshire hospital and 2.6 is
just a lot of
money thank you for the question Ellen
Leo I'm the CEO at New Hampshire
hospital um great question so in regards
to excuse me the need to um consider
this funding um yes there was funding
allocated to the entry point of the
forensic hospital um during our security
assessments that have occurred in recent
months and in conjunction with the
forensic Hospital planning it was noted
that um of course the entry point to the
forensic hospital is the same as the
entry point into the main hospital of
New Hampshire hospital so there was work
and efforts in design into creating um
some distinct entry criteria and
equipment related to the forensic
Hospital specifically however with the
security design um feedback that was
received in post events that occurred at
New Hampshire hospital safety related
recently it was decided that the that
renovation really needed to Encompass
the entirety of the entry into New
Hampshire hospital and not just
specifically to the forensic component
of the build so this um is work that was
performed by our architect as well as
equipment that was uh recommended by
security expertise in order to not only
address the needs of the forensic
Hospital entry point but incorporate
that into the main entry point of the
facility in its
entirety well up so um I I I I'm not
trying to second guess the Architects
I'm just it just makes me curious now
are are are you going to need to be
building out in front of where New
Hampshire hospital is now to get the
real estate to be able to have a joint
uh vestibule or are you going to remain
within the confines of the New Hampshire
Hospital's entrance thank you for the
question it's the ladder so we're going
to remain within the confin of New
Hampshire Hospital's entrance and there
is some wiggle room associated with that
space currently as well as with the
plans with the forensic hospital already
addition of the forensic hospital
already so this work will be encompassed
within the current footprint of both the
current state of New Hampshire hospital
and the forensic Hospital
build I I think that's great you've
answered everything uh I I I just want
to let you know that since that visit
not me posting about it
I have gotten some really heated
comments about the lack of parking and
you told me that you know you're 50
short but uh so the that's not for today
I just want to leave that with you dly
noted thank you very
much further questions on item
2492 Senator rosenal moves to adopt the
item Senator dallesandro seconds further
discussion seeing none are you ready for
the question all in favor say I I oppose
no that item is adopted we'll move on to
item you might as well stay there item
94 0
24094 and representative Edwards is
again recognized for
question okay so these are potentially
hard questions um to answer in public
but but uh I I see on page
three there are five bullet items those
five and the state has been funding
substance abuse disorder initiatives for
years now uh these five bullets um sound
like they're the beginning of something
and we are way way way down stream from
beginning something and so um I I think
I understand that the farum center has
had an economic reset and this is needed
to reboot them but so then the hard
question gets to be really um do
we need them is it our job as the state
to go in and rescue uh failing entities
do we have enough existing capacity
without
them I'm I'm just wondering if this is
the right invest M to intervene in the
marketplace I I'd like to know what you
think Miss
Fox good morning I'm ktia Fox I'm the
director of the division for Behavioral
Health these are all really good
questions and questions that we have
ourselves and I think that by embarking
on this um we're going to be able to
answer pretty quickly um about the need
I can tell you they have 77 beds 27 of
those are for detox and that is um a
very high amount um and at a level that
no um very few other providers um have
they also have um 40 residential beds
and 10 respit beds for that are
associated with the doorway farum Center
is a one of our Legacy organizations
it's a nonprofit it has served man
Chester and all of the state for many
many years in a very um effective way
and what's um really important is that
they serve everybody so they're serving
they you know they accept Medicaid they
serve the uninsured they serve the
underinsured um and private pay and so I
would say they're very much needed um
and we're going to have this opportunity
to be able to do that
um examination by providing them the
breathing room to be able to transform
into a model that's sustainable uh from
a financial standpoint and meets the
needs of the
individuals
followup thank you for that um I
appreciate your answer I I I'm I'm still
trying to get at uh the the idea of um
if we let them fail uh is
there adequate capacity in the market uh
and I think the answer to that is no we
need the capacity it sounds pretty
significant so the so so the follow on
question to that is
um if we let them fail is there another
white night entity that would come in
and uh take over the capacity that's got
a demonstrated track record of financial
success
ESS great questions um what is unique is
the people that farum serves and so yes
we could have a White Knight come in we
could have um capacity but not access
and so access for individuals who are um
Medicaid enroles who are uninsured is
very difficult without um a program like
farum
so so thank you Mr chair I you know I
I'm I'm really uncomfortable with this
proposal and uh I I may be the only one
that's this uncomfortable but I I would
like to move to table this
item first I'm going to accept a a
question from Senator rosemore thank you
Mr chairman thank you
representative um I had asked a question
about this item as well
um and the response we got back from the
Department was that it would be only
Bridge funding while Easter Seals looks
to De uh develop a sustainable
model what would that
sustainable model look like I mean would
it involve not taking people who are
uninsured uh limiting access to to
Medicaid enroll e how could farum become
financially sustainable because I don't
think we want to support them forever
and
ever so thank you Senator
um we don't know what that new model is
because this is a field that's emerging
and changing pretty rapidly and the
reason why we're here before you and why
farum and Easter Seals need the this
funding is to be able to model it out to
have that fiscal analysis to look at
programming to look at the needs that
they're serving today and how important
those are but what needs can they be
serving that are unmet and that um we
project into the future and so that's
where this assistance uh will come in
and in the meantime they need to keep
the doors
open you so are there models out there
for programs that do take all comers and
are
financially sustainable or does the very
nature of them taking all comers mean
they
need extra support all the time so right
now farum has 78% of their um the people
that they serve are uh Medicaid enroles
so a change in payer mix does make a
difference um
the models are out there um I can't
point to one in particular but again
this is why this analysis is needed and
to really dig deep to find out um is
this the the where we go in the future
or do we change but what my number one
uh purpose is is to keep access for
those that we are most vulnerable and
need service and need to have access on
a daily
basis comment follow up on the
prescription drug affordability board
last year we got a breakdown of the
number the highest prescribed drugs for
various Insurance Pairs and for Medicaid
the highest number of prescribed drugs
were the
medication assisted treatment drugs so
it's a very high needs population just a
comment thank you for your
Indulgence representative
Edwards so thank you m again Mr chair
and and so there was mentioned by Miss
Fox that we want to continue to keep the
facility open so that Services could be
continued uh I I may be missing it but
there's nothing in this proposal that
would help pay for the continuation of
services it it's all uh Strategic
Management planning and having once
written the Strategic plan it it feels
to me that we ought to be able to get
the same product for 10% of the request
here so I I I don't know that this is a
Justified amount really for the work
being requested so I apologize for that
not being being included in the letter
um the investment funding and looking at
new models and this is over a 18-month
period by the way not just one year um
is close to half a million and then the
bridge funding to uh maintain Services
is 1.7 million so that bulk of the
funding is to keep um the operations
going um and not have any disrupture in
the ongoing services so you're probably
being gentle with me saying that you
didn't put it in the write up but is it
really in the write up and I just
overlooked that breakdown I mean you can
correct me it's
okay if it's there it's there if it's
not it's not so it it we didn't include
the breakdown because typically we're
getting into the contractual elements
there which we submit to to GNC as as
the numbers that Kata quoted could
change through
negotiations um so generally speaking
the Department's pretty hesitant to put
very detailed specifics that are subject
to negotiation because they could change
and to bind us to the fiscal letter for
those very details could could prove
challenging if you look at the bottom of
page two what we tried to explain there
to to your point representative Edwards
was by requiring and supporting the
organization and it's that support that
I think we uh were not as clear as we
could have
been thank thank you for that and when
you're ready I I I think I still want to
uh propose a table to get this more
clear Is there further questions from
the any of the members before I accept a
tabling
motion represented thank you Mr chairman
so by providing this funding do you as
an agency ever go in there to audit or
look at their books and their expenses
and why they're coming up
short
so yes um we have a requirement in all
of our contracts with our um substance
use providers that they provide monthly
um financials and so we look at those on
a regular basis we also have been
working very closely with Easter Seals
to open up their books to take a deeper
dive into um their
finances representative
Earth does this facility support the
getting the people out of New Hampshire
hospital for instance and back into the
community is this part of that whole
process I would not say directly I think
that some in some instances someone may
um end up at farum Center their primary
uh purpose is to serve individuals who
have a substance use disorder um but
there is the co-occurring um mental
health conditions as
well there's no questions oh I
just represent I I think in this budget
cycle we did a lot to clean up and
streamline uh the authority of the
governor's Commission on alcohol and
drug abuse to invest without
interference uh from uh State leadership
and I I think I I and we made sure that
they had the full access to their 5% I'm
I I just think that we're we fully
funded substance abuse disorders and I
I'd like more homework done on this uh
please and your motion I have a motion I
don't know if it's it's not been
seconded but I've I've moved to
table motion to table is there a
second no one wishes to second the
motion dies is there a motion to adop
the
item Senator dallesandro seconded by
Senator birdell to adopt
2494 any further discussion seeing none
you ready for the question all in favor
say I I oppose no no how many NOS one
okay item is adopted thank you very
much moving on to tab nine and the
regular
calendar first item is
24099 Office of the
governor all right motion to approve the
item
by representative Lean leasman seconded
by Senator rosenal further discussion
seeing none all in favor say I I close
no 2499 is adopted moving on to
24 AB
24100 New Hampshire fishing game he's
been waiting patiently all this time any
discussion any questions on
24100 seeing none how do you wish to
proceed second Senator rosenal moves to
adopt Senator gray seconds further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted thank
you director and moving on to tab
11 judicial
councel second sen Senator Dallas Sandro
moves to adopt the item Senator gray
seconds is there any further
discussion seeing none you're ready for
the question all in favor say I I oppose
no that item is adopted late item
24-18 from governor's office emergency
relief and Recovery
funds no action that's just an it that's
an information item unless there's any
questions Senator rosenal you have a
question I think director cwell is
here good morning good morning
governor's office for emergency relief
and
Recovery Rosen for a question thank you
Mr chairman good morning commissioner so
when I look at this page there are three
items that jump out at me one is uh
emergency temporary housing support
which um as you and I have discussed was
basically putting people in
hotels um and we're turning back 7 and a
half million the mat withdrawal
management well maybe not mat the detox
money of $5 million and nothing was
spent and the preventing youth
homelessness where 19 million of the 25
million is being returned these items
were from two years ago and so my
question basically is what happened why
why are we hearing about this two years
later and um why specifically weren't
these monies spent if this is what we
thought we needed to address these needs
yes ma'am it's a complicated three part
question I guess yes yes it is a
complicated question and um um I'll do
my best to answer uh for you so the you
had the three items that you mentioned
here youth residential and the I'll
start with those two and the sud
withdrawal program um the youth
residential program was designed uh
initially to provide funding to do
substantial infrastructure enhancements
for uh eligible
organizations um under that program and
we designed the program in coordination
with other part parties including HHS uh
around what um the described need was at
the time and uh when we got the
approvals to the program we launched the
program uh we had very few applicants
and we made some adjustments to the
program to make more uh eligibility for
a wider scope of
population uh and that remained the case
we did get uh applications from a few
organizations but for the most part
those applications were not necessarily
for ma big infrastructure Investments
and expansions they were for things like
HVAC systems and smaller cost items so
in the end yes that program was one of
uh a couple of programs that uh resulted
in underuse and so they've you know over
the course of there's a number of things
that have to happen after we did we we
um recognized that a program might be
underused and the biggest one in terms
of time is the fact that we do allow
these programs to stay open for some
period of time in order to accommodate
any unanticipated costs that might come
as a result so unpaid invoices and such
so we leave those open for quite some
time to be able to not have to go back
at some point to a program that has been
fully closed out um and then secondly um
because there there are some of these
programs but I wouldn't say there are a
lot it is not a pro it is not um our
focus is on the the existing programs
both within gopher and with other
agencies to make sure that those
programs are operating efficiently and
spending and having their burn rates to
meet all of the the stat the regulatory
deadlines that we have and so uh in the
in the course of um reallocating it's
more of a scheduled sort of reallocation
process than it is uh you know as we get
it so I I I don't know if that answers
your question on the process I would say
uh with regard to the homelessness is
item that we discussed so you may recall
um back uh sometime a couple years ago
now when we were administering the
emergency rental relief program and uh
that was uh being done uh by New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority uh
that program was one where there were
two separate uh Federal programs ra1 and
ra2 both had slightly different rules
associated with them and there were
rules associated with how you spent
those funds and how you could apply for
more from the federal government we were
in a position where that program was
getting a lot of use to help individuals
pay the rent in their uh in their
wherever they were living and so uh we
had been repeatedly requesting
additional funds to come back from the
federal government and they would go
through whatever process they would go
through to um to redistribute any funds
that they had among on all states that
were requesting them so at the time I
believe we were uh in December I want to
say 21 but it might have been 22 where
we had a situation where we were running
low on those funds and we had limited
locations to be able to put people in
going into the the the cold winter and
so that's when the question of Hotel uh
usage came up and the use of ER funds
the the emergency rental relief program
uh to to pay for those we were at a
point in time where we had not heard
back from the federal government so the
decision was made to use arpa funds to
cover that that hotel cost and that was
in the amount of $20
million um that the bulk of those funds
were used um I believe the final number
was around 17 million and in the end
when we did see a
u a um an additional payment from the
federal government for the Emergency
rental relief program we took 5 million
of that to effectively reimburse the
arpa funds which then went through that
whole process of write down and
contractually coming back from New
Hampshire Housing and ended up on this
list further
question but so in terms of the timing
because this was
the ER one and two
was some time
ago did you just find out that we
weren't spending these funds or could we
have known about it last spring when we
were working on the state budget and
perhaps we could have looked at what we
were doing with State funds different ly
to address homelessness
and we haven't talked about the
withdrawal program yet could we have
known this last spring while at least
the Senate still had control of the
budget yes so so so again I would say
and i' have to go back to to look at all
the exact timing but let's just for
conversation sake say that as we got to
spring sometime in you know mid April we
were clear that there was not going to
be any additional expenditures under
that program the ER program itself was
still in operation and involved a very
significant amount of administration to
uh to maintain that program uh and to
begin the process of closing down those
programs uh is within that system that
we would have also been going through
the same process as it related to any
arpa funds that were related to that and
and and I would just emphasize that
there are there is a significant amount
of administrative and Regulatory burden
that we uh have to navigate when we work
through the proper use of these funds we
don't want to be in a position where we
are saying to the legislature we've got
an extra amount of money here for you to
be able to utilize um but it and then
have to come back and say oh we were
wrong we have to make sure that's
absolutely correct and um and we're
facing the deadlines as you know coming
up at the end of this year and uh we are
in a somewhat constant juggling process
to make sure that we're fully aware of
where those resources are and what their
what their spend rates are so that we're
in a position to make sure that all of
the funds that we possibly can are
obligated adequately by the end of this
year so
that whole process
involves um a good amount of work and I
hate to blame it on Administration and
bureaucracy but in many cases that is
the that is the reason why um we are
might be aware of a final number but we
aren't able to completely confirm that
number to the extent that I can come and
say we're ready to spend that money
again follow up the withdrawal
management 5 million that none of it was
spent what was the timing on you must
have set up a program no one bid on it
when did we know that that $5 million
was not going to be spent at
all so looking at my notes here and and
I would say
if I don't have the final dates and I
would I would I would ask if I could get
you that um because that's a very good
question uh I know that we
um the initial program closed in um the
spring of 2023 but I don't have the
exact date so let me get that for you
Senator and I will get back to
you all right any further questions on
this informational
item doesn't require a a dispositive
motion any other of the information
items anyone wishes to have
explained
question on the HHS dashboard
okay the
um dashboard the dashboard
24105 thanks um on table nine the
elderly if you look at midlevel
CFI for January it fell off a
cliff by 90% of the case load what
happened I I think someone's finger fell
off their keypad um it it it looks like
a data entry error okay and and I'm
waiting to verify that once I verify
that I'll get right back to you thank
you of course good
catch yeah
that that is a
surprise all right representative
Edwards uh thank you uh Mr
chair coming in today I heard a very
static broken up news report that there
was a significant uh incident at
Hamstead
hospital and um I'm and and we you all
have worked so hard to get controls and
you've had success getting controls of
situations at Hamstead since the state
took over so I'm just curious um if you
could tell us what you can about the
incident and if you think this incident
is indicative of a of a new trend or is
this an anomaly or you know what what's
your what's your thought on
it uh good morning Marissa hen Deputy
Commissioner at DHHS um and I oversee
Hampstead um um thank you for the
question uh and as you've probably heard
on the news this week um we are having a
rocky period at Hamstead um and uh much
as we had a challenging month or so over
the summer what we have right now are a
very small number of very complicated
kids who have acute mental health issues
layered on top of um long histories of
um trauma and adversity and that
presents itself in the course of their
treatment as escalated behaviors at
times um what I can tell you is that the
quality of care and the safety of that
facility is superb um for those of us
including many of you who spend time
inside that facility contrary to what
you may hear on the news reports it's a
place of healing it's a place of calm
and it's a place where occasionally that
is interrupted on a couple units due to
a small number of Youth so um we you
know just I want to provide a little
history but I think what I want to just
acknowledge first off is that the the
situation there is a stable one and we
have a couple youth that are difficult
and we have an incredible staff who are
rising to the challenge of using the
best therapeutic modalities to address
those needs and get those kids the
services they need not just during their
Hospital stay but to help return them to
the community and and into lives of of
hopefully a a brighter um
future just remember historically
Hamstead previously before the state
purchased it had a very different
patient population um Hamstead Hospital
under its prior for-profit ownership
played a really important role in New
Hampshire's system of care but it was
one that was limited to less acute
patients who didn't exhibit the
challenging behaviors we're seeing one
of our commitments informed by Advocates
by the child advocate by the legislature
is to keep kids here in New Hampshire
who often have some of the biggest
challenges and struggles in their lives
and not do what occurred previously
which was look for facilities far away
that could accommodate them part of The
Growing Pains of that challenge is
making sure that we can serve them well
while limiting the disruption to the
overall millu and the burden on local
law enforcement and that's what we're
going to do so under our new CEO Justin
lucer who comes from um not only a
clinical behavioral health background
but an exception history in terms of his
ability to help hospitals in New England
adapt to the challenges of high Acuity
High escalated patients we're getting
there but there's going to be some
bumpier weeks and we are you know
committed to doing everything to
supporting our staff making sure they
and patients feel safe and get the care
they need without um giving up on kids
who need our support and uh a facility
that truly is a place of quality and
healing um
today
followup thank you for the followup so
so what I think I took away from that is
that uh we may actually H be on a cusp
of a new trend because of a particular
subset of patients that are there uh
this this we should not expect this
incident to be an anomaly and the last
incident it's just the the next one in
some reasonably
predictable U likelihood of future
events I think the way that I would
answer that more directly is this
facility is absolutely committed and on
track to meet the challenges of serving
an acute population of complicated kids
who have nowhere else to go and we are
committed to not giving up on them not
simply resorting to you know their
languishing in emergency departments or
far away States um what I would say is
the data that we're tracking over time
well I don't want to minimize the house
scary some of these situations are for
staff and how much um complexity it
presents for the incredible First
Responders in the Hamstead Community as
well as State Police and Beyond um this
is uh this is a we are going to have
situations that are escalated if you
were to look at data from other um
hospitals across the country if you were
to look at data as our CEO has shared
from hospitals he worked at it's not out
of the ordinary for us to occasionally
have situations where we need to call on
police 911 Etc we're not a medical
facility um so when someone uh you know
tries to hurt themsel for example we
have to seek EMT support and sometimes
even local hospital support just as any
other program serving kids would um so
the answer to the question is the kids
aren't going to go away we have um we
have youth who are probably about 1% of
those DHHS serves who um have very very
acute complex needs their behavior years
at time over the course of treatment
will escalate what will change is that
we are fully committed to being able to
manage the vast majority of those on our
own um and as you know the the contract
for a clinical vendor is there will be a
new contract this summer and whether
it's the current vendor or a new vendor
that's also an opportunity to revisit
how our approaches clinically
programmatically bureaucratically are
working to make sure that we're rising
to that
challenge thank you for the answer and I
I and my concern is just we haven't
built the new Youth Development Center
and I'm still just worried about ongoing
community support for that new facility
so I appreciate your answer I understand
it completely just just I'm worried
about ongoing Community
issues Senator Rosen question Senator
Dallas Andro and
Senator so I've had
conversations with the commissioner and
the associate commissioner about one
particular child who experienced very
long ER
stay and in the end hamad's PT prtf
declined to take this child um and so
the answer was to go to another state my
question is since we own this place what
is Our obligation to serve the children
of New Hampshire
versus sending them away from their
families and out of state are those
decisions made clinician to clinician
are they made by the administrative
staff does the department get involved
to say this is one of New Hampshire's
kids this is a public hospital and
prdf we need to treat our own children
where where is that have
responsibility it's a great question and
what I would say is when it comes to um
some of the youth who uh again this
being New Hampshire in a relatively
small state um I'm very familiar with
the case you're talking about and and uh
and many of the first names of these
youth who struggle the most become ones
that we um we all know because we are
bringing together the department and all
the parts that are involved in their
care to be more coordinated um that also
involves close communication and
improved communication with our other
providers in the community including
those hospitals where some of these um
youth uh are are staying I mean one of
the things I think what I the way I
would answer the question is we build
the the system of care in New Hampshire
this Continuum of supports from
community-based and prevention and
screening through the more um wraparound
supports for families in their
communities all the way up into
residential and impatient um it's it's a
big it's a big process of of um
unfolding that and we're we're a few
years in so what we as a department are
doing right now is an assessment of
where we are succeeding and where we
need improvements and changes one of
those as I mentioned is making sure that
Hamstead is prepared and supported to
serve the types of Youth that's serving
both in a residential facility at the
you know that campus at the future YDC
and and and the hospital of course
um but there are clearly you know it's
only been two years that we've even had
contracts for residential providers um
such as at the prtf so what we will do
in this assessment is identify where are
we um where is it working and where are
the gaps and how do we through the
budget process through legislation
through programmatic change fill those
in and so an example will be thinking
about those youth Who currently are not
able to um are too disruptive to the
millu in the prtf we can't we have to
find a way to serve them and it may be
that we need a hybrid approach but what
we're doing through this assessment is
looking at what other states have done
who are in the similar situation is it
because of intellectual and
developmental disabilities is it because
of specialized medical needs how do we
make sure that the vast majority
basically 99% or higher are staying
within State um and so I think we are
we're getting there but it is going to
take more time assessment and then quick
action to to finally be able to
accommodate all of those youth including
the ones like the one you're referring
to who we um who we deeply want to serve
close to
home senator dallesandro for a question
thank you Mr chairman we have this
conversation earlier and I appreciated
your response very very much I've been
around here a long time I remember Toby
I remember Toby and our solution was YDC
uh we were going to make the YDC we took
that money from the federal government
we were going to solve that problem um
we got this other situation where we
sent kids out of state which bounced
back on us in a very negative fashion
now we have the situation at hamston uh
and and the question is we're going
through a process here
and I I think the key to the process is
communication to let us know what what
is going on MH at any time you get the
the the news media involved in it it
changes the whole perspective of of that
situation that's why I called you and
tried to get what what was really go
going on there and I think that's the
critical issue we we've been evolving
I've been here for 50 years we've been
in an evolutionary process for the last
50 years and and the way to address this
one was to get to by Hemstead hospital
to take take students that we were
sending out of state retain them at at
Hamstead hospital do the best we can as
as far as treatment morality is
concerned I I think there's there's a
risk associated with all of this it and
I I think our job is to take that risk
and reduce it it and by by doing the
things we're doing hopefully we are
going to accomplish that that takes care
of uh the majority of of the population
so I I I think communication is the key
in letting letting us know the players
in this game what what what's going
on that to me that that is that's the
key Mr CH and if there's a breakdown
there then everyone
loses thank you thank you Senator Bell
for a question thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my
question excuse me um
who I just learned about the incident
this morning from someone else but who
was the First Responders was it Hamstead
uh police again EMTs who responded first
I believe it was a a mix um of both
State Police and Hamstead police last
night okay follow up follow up
um as you know in the um Youth
Development Center meeting we've we've
been discussing this is there
any
um was there someone there to greet the
First Responders when they got there
this
time we we're this the leadership team
is currently in meetings um making sure
to identify you know to to review what
happened and to understand if there's
any room for improvement as well as
ensure that going into the weekend we
hopefully have some quieter days but but
you've brought that up importantly um
and I think it builds on Senator delis
Sandra's point it's communication at a
at a conquered level at a sort of
strategic and and oversight level it's
also Communication in a micro sense of
making sure that when incidents occur we
are managing them with local responders
in a way that's maximally effective and
respectful of everyone
involved final question final question
um as you
know in speaking with the
um select board and the um police
they're getting continuously F
frustrated by the continued calls that
they have to do um is there any look at
trying it typically the state police are
supposed to be the the ones in charge of
and we know they're way down and is
there any process or thoughts about
putting maybe um stationing some police
at that facility so that they will be
there in case something like this
happens so we're in conversations again
as we as we look at the overall safety
model um you know per the earlier item
there are in general there's safety
assessments going on um across state
campuses right now uh about an array of
situations inside outside um and we
actually have as um councelor Stevens
mentioned it at governor and Council
this week we have the results of an
overall safety assessment being
delivered by um Homeland Security next
week so combined with that as well as
the new contract that's being um
developed and will be released this
summer or issu or in place this summer
um we are always open to looking at that
in general um from a hospital security
standpoint um there aren't permanent
police that are usually um in these
facilities uh nationally that tends not
to be a a practice um there are um
safety staff that are integrated into
the millu who get to know the kids who
build trust but who also have some
specialized skills um I think for now
that is the approach that we are seeking
but as you and I have had probably hours
of conversation this week um we're open
to all ideas to learning from other
models um but fundamentally we want to
be able to We believe We can solve for
these issues through a clinical and
therapeutic approach um and and reduce
the Reliance on First Responders that's
what that's what best practice tells us
we can be able to do by having the right
activities by wrapping supports around
the kids by keeping them busy um
adolescents tend to stay out of trouble
um that is that is where we are
emphasizing um approaches while also
digging into conversations with Homeland
Security and police about what do we
need to make the whole Community feel
safe and make that campus um stable as
well final
question final comment I guess I just
want you to um be aware that as the
First Responders um get
frustrated the residents of Hamstead are
starting to pay attention especially
when you have the media uh owning in on
it the residents are starting to get
pretty frustrated so we I my feeling is
we need to get this
moving quicker yeah thank you thank you
any further requests for the inform
information on the informational items
from the committee members seeing none
before we move on to the audits um like
to set the date for the next
meeting uh April 19th is the third
Friday which is the
traditional one we usually shoot
for is there any problems on that date
with anybody's schedule at the present
moment 19th of
April it's
okay all right let's 10:00 on the 19th
of
April Representatives any
problem all right expect the Senate
might be a little busier than we
are okay let's get ready for
Audits and you'll tell us what one we'll
do first
yes and thank you all for coming and
waiting patiently if we needed your
response
all right we got four different audits
which one are we going to take up
first good morning Mr chairman and uh
committee members for the record I'm
Christine Young director of audits for
the LBA uh we're here to present several
audit reports this morning um the first
of which is the performance audit of the
uh Department of Education special
education dispute resolution
processes uh Paige Loren uh an audit
manager with our office was the InCharge
manager on this audit and she will
present the report also joining us from
the Department of Education is Christine
Brennan the Deputy Commissioner of the
department who will be available for
comments and questions and with that
I'll turn over to paig for the
presentation of the
report good morning my name is Paige
Lauren and I'll will be presenting the
Department of Education special
education dispute resolution processes
audit
report the purpose of our audit was to
assess how effectively did the
Department of Education manage special
education dispute resolution processes
during State fiscal years 2020 through
2022 we reviewed over, 1600 regulatory
requirements and corresponding internal
controls for for six processes available
through the department to help parents
and schools resolve special education
disputes these were primarily issues
related to students with an
individualized education program or
IEP our executive summary starts on page
one we found the department lacked
adequate controls and did not
effectively manage dispute resolution
processes existing controls were limited
informal inconsistently implemented and
not clearly documented or
communicated dispute resolution
requirements were unnecessarily complex
an issue we first reported on in
1991 many Department requirements were
established through ad hoc rules which
could not be enforced we also found
Department practices were not always
consistent with laws and rules
ineffective internal controls and the
resulting issues we identified
compromise compliance and transparency
and potentially compromise State
eligibility for federal
assistance ineffectiveness also added
unnecessary costs and barriers for
parents and other
stakeholders
our recommendation summary begins on
page
five the department concurred fully or
in part with all 20 of the observations
in the report five observations may
require legislative
action each of the six dispute
resolution processes is summarized in
our background section starting on page
11 table one on page 12 also list each
process available through the
department our management control
chapter starts on page 27 and contains
eight observations addressing
deficiencies systemically affecting
special education dispute resolution
processes well-designed properly
implemented and monitored controls can
help eff efficiently and effectively
achieve objectives ensure
responsibilities are fulfilled and
ensure operations remain
consistent however as we discussed in
observation numbers 1 2 and three
management oversight of the existing
limited controls was ineffective there
were no strategies user plans aligning
dispute resolution processes to a
department-wide mission to achieve
objectives and inadequate organizational
controls adversely affected dispute
resolution efficiency and
Effectiveness processes were generally
managed independent of each other and
management significantly relied on staff
members institutional knowledge to carry
out
operations as a result non-compliance
occurred responsibilities were not
always fulfilled performance and
decision-making were not supported by
quantitative assessments and known risks
were
unmitigated additionally observ
observation number four on page 40
addresses stakeholder engagement and
collaboration processes which are
critical for management to understand
and set dispute resolution
expectations formalizing engagement
collaboration processes could help the
department promote transparency support
process Improvement and use resources
efficiently however we found stakeholder
engagement and collaboration processes
were not formalized and buried among
stakeholders this compromise
transparency contributed to inefficiency
and
Effectiveness starting on page
45 observation numbers 5 and six address
effective contract management controls
and ensuring enough qualified
individuals are contracted for dispute
resolution
processes we found existing controls
were minimal and un and unimplemented
and monitoring was
inadequate contract terms were
incomplete and terms included in
contracts were inconsistently fulfilled
which contributed to
non-compliance management did not
formalize training requirements nor did
management ensure the department
contracted with enough qualified
individuals to fulfill dispute
resolution Regulatory and contract
requirements including for the
scheduling of
contractors observation number seven
starts on page
55 the observation addresses controls
over conflicts of interest for
Department staff contractors and parties
to dispute resolution
processes we found controls were not
comprehensive and conflicts of interest
risk were not sufficient
mitigated impartiality and Independence
requirements for staff and contractors
were inconsistently understood
implemented and followed additionally
parents did not always know how to
report potential conflicts of interest
we identified several actual conflicts
of interest which occurred for one
dispute resolution process during the
audit
period observation number eight starts
on page
60 the observation addresses developing
controls to comprehensively understand
monit monetary and non-monetary costs
associated with administering special
education dispute resolution
processes we found Associated controls
are inadequate which resulted in waste
and increased fraud risk the department
also did not identify improvements to
help address cost to stakeholders while
using dispute resolution
processes our regulatory framework
chapter starts on page 65 and contains
six
observations observation numbers 9
through 14 address Federal requirements
the development and implementation of
state requirements through laws rules
policies and procedures and ensuring
requirements are effectively
communicated to the public and relevant
stakeholders the department lacked
procedures to help ensure necessary
changes to its dispute resolution
regulatory framework were timely and
comprehensive state law and Rule
inconsistently reflected Federal
requirements conflicted with each other
or were ambiguous and did not include
Authority for two of the six dispute
resolution processes available
many dispute resolution practices and
requirements were informally developed
over time without appropriate adoption
into rule were not documented or
properly communicated internally and
externally and could not be
enforced our performance and enforcement
chapter starts on page 87 and contains
six
observations effective Performance
Management helps provide a basis for
making objective data informed decisions
well-controlled enforcement procedures
could increase the likelihood outcomes
are efficiently and effectively achieved
however as we discussed in observation
numbers 15 16 and 17 the department did
not have sufficient and accurate data to
evaluate efficiency and effectiveness of
dispute resolution
processes there was no department-wide
tracking or monitoring of dispute
resolution processes to identify Trends
and address issues available dispute
resolution process outputs were limited
unreliable and primarily focused on
federal reporting requirements while
other quantifiable goals objectives and
targets were not developed result
resulting in non-compliance with State
reporting
requirements local educational agency
compliance with the requirements was not
monitored or enforced nor did the
department ensure decision decisions and
agreements resulting from dispute
resolution processes were implemented
which contributed to Management's
inability to determine efficiency
Effectiveness and achievement of
outcomes we also found dispute
resolution agreements to be generally
unregulated resulting in stakeholders
expressing concerns about the use of
certain terms and conditions parents
reported fears of violating agreements
because of these terms and conditions
this directly affected legislators the
Departments and our ability to obtain
quality feedback for process
improvements from these
stakeholders observation number 18
starts on page
101 the observation addresses developing
a Public Communication System to ensure
complaints are fully
addressed and external Communications
are timely and effective we found the
department did not establish and
publicize clear lines of commun
communication including instructions and
law rules and guidance for stakeholders
to formally file requests and complaints
allegations were not always fully
addressed and non-compliance with
certain notice and posting requirements
occurred observation numbers 19 and 20
start on page
105 these observations address records
and data management controls reliable
records and data are necessary for
measuring performance supporting
decisions and evaluating risk risk
management control should be developed
in accordance with relevant laws and
rules including additional additional
confidentiality requirements in federal
and state
laws we found the department lacked
records management policies and
procedures resulting in records being
incomplete missing or untimely provided
to management at times records lacked
sufficient documentation and were not
auditable the Department's ability to
effectively management manage two
dispute resolution processes was limited
in part due to unclear and conflicting
record restrictions in state law
addressing our recommendations will and
making improvements to special education
dispute resolution processes will likely
be a multi-year undertaking however
conducting a comprehensive analysis of
the Department's dispute resolution
regulatory framework evaluating current
responsibilities developing a risk-based
approach to prioritize needs and
developing and implementing related
plans should help assist management with
making Necessary
changes I would like to thank the
department for their help during the
audit management and staff were
cooperative and work worked hard to meet
our reporting
timelines unless there are any questions
for me I will turn over to Deputy
Commissioner Christine Brennan for
questions thank you very thorough
representative Edwards has a question
thank you Mr chair as I'm looking at
your recommendations and skimming
through the some of the part partially
concur comments uh it it dawned on me to
ask the
question um do do as you were doing the
audit did you do an evaluation of the
existing Workforce within the this
department to determine whether or not
they they actually had the requisite
skill set to properly interpret this
guidance and to be able to lead the an
effort like this this is this is this is
serious management issues here as
opposed to um uh working the human
component of dispute resolution and so
I'm wondering if we have a skill set u
problem I'll let Chris Christine Brennan
speak a little bit more to it and I
don't mean to criticize anyone there
because I don't know anyone there I just
want to make sure that I mean this is
this is this is stuff people go to
school for and study and get to be
really good at I'm just wondering if
they have the the workforce to to
execute this and for for our audit work
purposes it in in observation number
three organizational management controls
some of those concerns are brought up in
terms of having enough resources to
carry out these responsibilities
so good afternoon I think it's close to
that time Christine Brennan Department
of Education um first of all I wanted to
thank Christine Young and Paige because
we did have um and my team back there we
did have beautiful thorough
conversations and we were all in
agreement that serving um people with
special needs and making sure that
family understand the processes are um
there were were there are things that
can always be improved I want to thank
you for your question because that did
commit come up in the our conversations
for example our hearing officers and um
their role their history was that before
we didn't use hearing officers and it's
best that we do and sometimes getting
those contracts and hiring people with
those skill sets is difficult another um
another way in which we looked at that
is looking at the I P facilitate
facilitated process where we need people
with expertise in the uh process and
finding those people to fill fulfill the
contract to help the schools make the
decisions and I think another part of it
is and the human part that you're
talking about is some of these decisions
when kids are when there's a dispute at
the local level we want to solve those
problems as quickly as possible so that
kids are getting uh services and that
they need and that families and schools
can come to a a faster
agreement does that answer your
question no because I like yes and or no
either either the requisite skill set is
already available to implement this
these fixes or it's not and we have to
go find somebody with the requisite
skill sets to add so I'm I was looking
for a yes or no but I understand your
answer further
questions representative
thank you Mr chair could you email us a
copy of your presentation that you're
reading
from so all of these are posted on
YouTube with the captions next to it and
then I'm going to defer to my director
if okay post on YouTube sounds like a
video well this is streaming on YouTube
and it's observed no no could you
actually email us a copy of what you
were reading from representative we'll
have a transcript um we typically don't
give out our presentations we could have
notes and everything on it but we will
have a transcript of the meeting with
everything that P said on a verb attim
okay that's fine I guess I was just ask
in general we it' be nice if we could
get those I mean the executive summary
is obviously much shorter than what she
read okay and then what she read is much
smarter than what's here okay and it
really provides a much better map to the
whole document I think that's generally
true of any of these but this is
particularly okay Hefty one Absolutely
I'll talk to Christine and Jay Henry
sure
representative
so this is really more of a question I
think for Mr Cain and um M
representative Wier but this um audit
will be forwarded to the education
Committee of the House and
Senate we do um yes we usually send this
to the chair of the relevant policy
committees uh our audit will provide the
necessary
copies and when when do you think this
will go to
them a next
week and one other question do you
arrange with them to have a presentation
and um have similar to what we've had
here today it depends on the chair
sometimes the chair requests a
presentation so there are instances
where we do there are other instances
where we aren't requested to present so
um if you think it would be something
that's helpful I'd probably reach out to
the house education chair s reach out to
the Senate education chair and and we
can definitely provide our offic and
definitely provideed uh a detailed
presentation to them as
well Mr I I would like to request that
where we follow up with having the um
education committee at least in the
house and I don't know about the how the
Senate feels about it but in the house
that the education committee um take a
look at this and have a thorough review
of it okay I can reach out something we
also like to do is especially with
something this extensive is get hear
from the Department on say a quarterly
basis your progress on these items
because there's many items listed and
you have to list them and tell us what's
going on in progress also since the
fiscal committee has a responsibility of
of dealing with the
fiscal changes I mean the legislative
changes I need a u a liaison from
Department of Ed to help us with that
and and help formulate it some of us
will be the co-sponsors unfortunately
nothing will happen probably till next
year on as far as getting legislation
filed we passed our deadlines but we
will be ready to file some legislation
on these items that require it so I need
a I need a Lia on who I can deal with
Education First Senator D thank you
thank you Mr CH I would I would e Echo
the sentiments of Representative Walder
although no one from Senate education
is here I I think that the presentation
before the Senate education committee is
really an imperative based on the
document that was presented to us
there's a lot here and and I think uh
our people should really get their wrap
their abs around it's quite significant
so I hope that we could pass that on to
our education people I'll I'll work with
that thank you yes we will do so
anything
further thank you very much and and a
motion from representative
F uh move to accept place on file and
release the public release to the public
in in the usual
manner motion is there a second second
by Senator gray any further discussion
all in favor say I I oppose no okay
we'll be in touch thank you very
much
like
correct okay all right welcome okay for
the second audit we'd like to present
our assessment of the internal controls
in place over the salary and benefit
expenditures at the Department of
Corrections Kimberly Bisson senior
manager with our office was the InCharge
manager on the audit and she will
present the report and also joining us
from the Department of Corrections is
Helen Hanks commissioner of the
department who will be available for
comments and questions and with that
I'll turn it over to
Kimberly good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Kimberly Bisson and I will be
presenting the report on our assessment
of the internal controls in place over
the authorization payment recording and
reporting of the Department of
Correction salaries and benefits
expenditures during the nine months
ended March 31st
2023 if you turn to the table of
contents you will see that the report
contains 15 findings and recommendations
one of which suggests legislative action
may be required
auditing responses were provided either
by the Department of Corrections
Department of administrative services or
the department of Information Technology
and are included following each finding
in the report the Departments concurred
fully in part fully or in part with 14
observations and did not concur with one
observation the department operates
three prisons the New Hampshire state
prison for men the New Hampshire
correctional facility for women and the
Northern New Hampshire correction
facility as well as the secure
psychiatric unit and the residential
treatment unit the department also
operates the corrections transitional
work center and transitional housing
units in addition the Department's
division of field services has district
offices located in each County
throughout the state to accommodate
probation and parole
officers the division of personnel and
information is located at the
Department's headquarters and is
responsible for the administrated
administration of payroll benefit
benefits and human resource functions
the Department's payroll process is one
of the most complex within the state
during the 9 months ended March 31st
2023 the department employed 791 people
operated under six different collective
bargaining agreements and paid out
approximately $ 86.3 million in salaries
and benefits
expenditures on top of this complexity
of operations the department served as
one of two pilot agencies for the
State's new workforce management system
and dealt with severe Staffing shortages
experiencing vacancy rates of up to 50%
for correctional officers as a result
its existing correctional officers were
frequently required to work between
three and five mandatory 8h hour
overtime shifts per week the department
was also compelled at times to call upon
the assistance of the New Hampshire
National
Guard on page three you will find a
summary of the Department salaries and
benefits expenditures for the nine
months ended March 31st 202 three and a
breakdown of the Department's employees
by the respective collective bargaining
bargaining agreements is located on page
four we conducted our audit in
accordance with government auditing
standards the objective of the audit was
to evaluate whether the department has
designed implemented and operated
suitable internal controls over the
authorization payment recording and
recording of its salaries and benefits
expenditures as reported in the summary
of results beginning on page one
we found that the department had not
established adequate internal controls
over the authorization payment recording
and reporting of salaries and benefits
expenditures during the nine months
ended March 31st
2023 while the Department's controls
over new hires pay changes and
timekeeping were tested and found to be
operating effectively certain other
necessary controls were not properly
designed implemented or operating
effectively additionally some salary and
benefits EXP expenditures may not have
been paid in accordance with applicable
statutes administrative
role and Department of administrative
Services policies and
procedures the audit objective scope and
methodology are described on pages five
and six and the observations begin on
page
seven observation number one notes that
the internal control structure in place
at the Department of Corrections during
the audit period exhibited numerous
weaknesses in each of the five
components of internal control which are
the control environment risk assessment
control activities information and
communication and monitoring these
weaknesses impacted its ability to
process salary and benefits expenditures
accurately and effectively and in
accordance with applicable collective
bargaining agreements administrative
Rule and the federal fair labor
standards act these weaknesses are
further discussed in detail in
observations 2-7 and
12-4
observation number two beginning on page
12 recommends that the department
establish and document a formal risk
assessment process supported by written
policies and procedures for identifying
monitoring and responding to risks risks
that could affect its ability to achieve
its objectives and also recommends that
the department establish document and
maintain business continuity and
Disaster Recovery plans for critical
administrative support and financial
reporting
activities moving on to page 13
observation number three recommends that
the department established formally
documented management approved policies
and procedures covering the Recruitment
and Retention incentive programs in
place at the department the policies and
procedures should cover all nuances of
the Department's incentive programs that
are necessary for its staff to comply
with the Statewide program
policies observation number four on page
16 identified weaknesses within the
Department's process C for allowing
employee use of Mobility punches to
clock in and out of scheduled shifts and
recommends that the department evaluate
the use of the mobility punch function
within the state's workforce management
system to determine whether the
identified potential misuses require
further investigation and whether
continued use of this function is
appropriate if continued use is deemed
appropriate the department should amend
its current time and attendance policy
to incorporate procedures covering the
use of Mobility punches and also work
with the Department of administrative
services to gain access to reports from
the workforce management system which
would allow for the periodic review of
those punches by
management continuing on to page 18
observation number five recommends that
the department develop and Implement
internal controls to ensure that manual
payroll check requests are clerically
accurate and calculated in compliance
with the applicable requirements ensure
staff requesting manual payroll checks
have appr rate training and establish
formally documented policies and
procedures observation number six on
page 20 recommends that the department
Implement policies and procedures and
provide training over the reallocation
process to ensure that future job
reallocations are sufficiently
controlled entered into New Hampshire
first correctly and are performed in
accordance with administrative
rule on page 21 observation number seven
recommends that the department
strengthen it monitoring and review
process by establishing formal policies
and procedures to to ensure its current
practices can be continued in the
absence or departure of key
employees observations number 8 through
11 beginning on page 22 are directed
towards the department of administrative
Services observations number eight and n
on pages 22 through 25 recommend that
the department of administrative
Services seek formal clarification from
the Attorney General's office to
determine whether whether it's
compensation practices for double time
pay and for academic employees were
carried out in accordance with the
applicable collective bargaining
agreements observation number 10 on page
26 recommends that the department of
administrative Services publish
non-exempt employee classification
listings as specified in the collective
bargaining agreements and observation
number 11 on page 27 recommends the
department to work with the Department
of information technology to ensure
backup data is periodically tested as
prescribed in the Statewide information
security
manual also on page 27 observation
number 12 recommends that the Department
of Corrections comply with RSA 21g colon
22 and the related executive branch
Ethics Committee advisory opinion
regarding conflicts of interest
including ensuring appropriate steps are
taken during the hiring process and to
establish controls to ensure employees
in familial relationships are not in a
position to review approve or
participate in transactions processed by
one another or to make important
management decisions without the
involvement and oversight of the
commissioner observation number 13 on
page 28 recommends the department
develop a
plan to ensure that its internal policy
and procedure directives are reviewed at
least every 3 years in accordance with
its established policy and observation
number 14 on page 29 recommends that
statements of financial interest be
filed in accordance with
statute lastly observation number 15 on
page 30 recommends that the department
seek statutory revision to ensure its
current organizational structure aligns
with
statute the appendix beginning on page
33 reports on the current status of
Prior audit findings the status key at
the bottom of page 34 shows that the
department has has fully resolved three
observations while two are in the
process of
remediation this concludes my
presentation I'd like to thank the
commissioner and the Department of
Correction staff as well as the
department of administrative services
for their cooperation throughout the
audit um I'll now turn the presentation
over to commissioner Hanks for any
comments she may
have
commissioner I don't know is it good
afternoon uh for the record Helen Hanks
commissioner of the Department of
Corrections uh you know I knew when this
it was going to come forward it was
going to be uh professionally painful uh
and that it was uh and uh also uh many
of you know that I advocated for
electronic Software System to make
improvements and assure you that even in
the areas where we did not uh concur in
in whole um we've been making
significant strides uh even since this
audit period to improve the process um
and it was uh to no shock that they
recommended additional uh payroll staff
because the size of the organization and
the complexity that was described based
on the number of bargaining agreements I
think this audit also affirms that as
one state that ourselves as a state
agency with our partners at Das and dit
need to have some uh collaboration and
policies that help all of us under this
uh Software System and other avenues um
navigate these things successfully and
clearly it is incredibly important to
pay the hardworking uh individuals
within our department and any state
agency correctly and not to impact their
Peg so certainly answer any specific
questions yeah it was rather surprising
to discover how many collective
bargaining agreements you have to deal
with I'm a lucky commissioner
sir and how how is the recruiting
efforts you still have a fairly large uh
vacancy rate uh we do but I will affirm
for you we've had significant um
increases in the number of recruits and
I'd like to make the comparison as a
singular law enforcement agency had just
graduated 20 new law enforcement
officers and I have 11 in the queue for
another Academy and so for our talent
acquisition group they're doing an
exceptional job and then the retention
side of the equation is equally
important we have a a decrease in people
exiting uh so I want to just appreciate
you all for supporting the arpa related
recruitment incentives the retention
incentives they have helped um steady
the ship while we continue to move
forward and the support of the
legislature through the budget process
and our reallocation um It's Made
significant uh strides in our success
and I appreciate that glad to hear we're
having some progress Senator Dall thank
just one point maybe the auditor could
address this one the the incentive
situation if if that isn't clearly
understood and not clearly applied if
there's a discrepancy there that cause
some concern it's a problems among the
among the staff what's what's what's
being done to address
that this is observation number three
you're asking about
yes I mean I can let Kimberly speak more
specifically to it but I think here
we're just recommending that the
department establish agency specific
policies and procedures related to those
programs um you know there's certain
nuances for each department and while
the department of administrative
Services has an overall Statewide policy
uh we recommended strengthening controls
by having an agency specific policy to
deal with the items listed on page 15
items 1 through five and we thought that
may help the department in uh
strengthening their procedures over this
process
okay thank you thank you Mr
CH
representative thank you Mr chair this
is actually with Mr Kane the same
comment as the previous one but ALS
regarding the presentation but also I
note that the summary of the there's no
summary basically of the recommendations
and the all that stuff it'd be nice to
have that as well sure so I'll have
meetings with our audit division just
kind of go over things that will be very
helpful for the legislature going
forward it's uh both performance and
financial um and we'll have those
conversations going for that you'd find
that very helpful to have it summarized
uh at well that's the summary of her
presentation yes but also the the almost
everyone I've seen has that summary at
the beginning which this was the the
previous one did with the of the
observations the legislative
recommendations the right the very
beginning of um if you look at the
performance one it was right at the very
start yeah starting on page
uh five of the prior audit right I don't
see that at the beginning of this one
okay we can uh we'll take a look at that
thanks
sure okay representative Earth for a
motion
uh move to accept play on file and
release to the public in the usual
manner Motion in a second from Senator
gray further discussion I will ensure
that the uh number 15 which requires
legislative correction uh give me a
contact for
liaison again it'll be next year before
any legislation starts to move forward
but we want to be ready for it so give
me a liaison we'd also appreciate maybe
some progress reports as you go and and
make these Corrections and at least on a
six-month basis give us some report on
what's going on happy to do that and
thank you for your offer I had a quick
question Mr
chairman push the
red uh followup to representative
delisandros in that item three yeah I
think it said there were like three
employees that received a $10,000
incentive as far as
hiring um
I guess I was under the misunderstanding
that incentives would be given if they
were hired and they met the one-year
requirement but these you had three
people apparently that left after they
received the 10,000 has that been
changed where someone has to at least
complete uh a year of service and then
they get the $10,000 or representative
Lehman the fiscal item that came before
had a specific time in which they would
be paid and it wasn't at the onee mark
But the fiscal item that did go before
you also indicated that if they left we
would work with the attorney generals to
recruit that money so we are in the
process of recouping those those dollars
from individuals yeah I saw i' mentioned
that you had reached out the Attorney
General any success here yet or uh not
yet but we are very much persevering all
right thanks so much thanks Mr chairman
all right we have a motion any further
discussion seeing none you ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
all right we'll see the criminal justice
gets
copies coming next looks like
Lottery
Okay the third audit uh these will be
our management letters um these audits
are a byproduct of our financial audits
for both uh the Lottery Commission and
Liquor Commission uh this first
presentation will be for Lottery
Commission uh with me to present the
report is Jean Mitchell she's the
financial audit supervisor from our
office who supervised the audit that our
senior manager Kimberly Bisson uh was
responsible for managing so we are
trying to sort of divide and conquer
here this morning uh oh this yeah this
afternoon at this point uh joining us
from the Lottery Commission is uh
Charlie McIntyre executive director and
John coni the chief compliance officer
to respond to any questions that you
might have um and with that I'll turn it
over to Jean for the presentation this
one should be much shorter than the
prior to
so good afternoon chairman wer members
of the committee for the record my name
is Jean Mitchell I'm the financial audit
supervisor and we're here today to
present the Lottery Commission fiscal
year 2023 management letter if you turn
to the table of contents you will see
that the report includes four internal
control comments none of which are
deemed material weaknesses and there's
two compliance comments and you'll note
observation number six suggests
legislative action may be required the
observations begin on page number
three observation number one notes
Lottery is unable to develop complete
and accurate expectations for its hor
historical horse racing Revenue
submitted by the gaming operators as
part of their monthly Revenue
reconciliation process free play wager
data a component of the reconciliation
is not included on some of the tote
system daily reports we recommend
Lottery consider amending historical
horse racing administrative rules to
require the submission of free play
activity if this is not
feasible Lottery should determine if
current mitigating controls should be
strengthened or further mitigating
controls could be
implemented turning on to page four is
observation number two we recommend
Lottery update its ineligible players
listing policy to require vendors and
partner organizations provide listing of
all employees working in the United
States to comply with muscle and lucky
for lifee gaming rules and vendor
contracts if Lottery believes its
current practice to be sufficient to
identify ineligible players Lottery
should amend its current vendor
contracts to ensure contract language
matches current practices and inquire of
gaming administrators to determine the
policy aligns with gaming
rules moving on to Observation number
three on page five we recommend Lottery
comply with its policy and formally
document its quarterly review of user
access permissions including the results
of the review it further recommends
procedures be implemented to ensure user
access is immediately removed for any
employee who leave the commission or
move to a new role where access is no
longer
required the final internal control
observation number four on page six
recommends Lottery establishing document
of form
management approved control procedure
for retailer promotional credits and
adjustments supported by formally
documented policies and
procedures the compliance observations
begin on page
eight with observation number
five and it notes two out of the four
tote system providers operating in the
state did not provide sock one type two
reports as required by administrative
rules this increases the risk that there
could be control gaps at the tote system
provider
which go unmitigated potentially
negative negatively impacting historical
horse racing revenues to the lottery we
recommend Lottery Implement policies and
procedures to ensure compliance and
consider the consequences when tote
system providers do not comply with
administrative
rules final observation number six on
page nine notes Lottery was not in
compliance with the $6 million banial
transfer limit required by the chapter
law for the Banning and ended June 30
2020 23 we recommend LW toy comply with
or seek to amend the banial transfer
limit outlined in the chapter law for
the B amended June 30
2025 the appendix located behind the tab
on page 11 reports the current status of
observations contained in our fiscal
years 2021 and 2022 management letters
as noted on page 13 one prior
observation is fully resolved and five
are in the process of being
remediated this concludes my
presentation I would like to thank the
Lottery Commission management and staff
for their assistance and cooperation
during the audit and with your
permission I will now turn the
presentation over to executive director
Charles McIntyre for any comments he
might have uh good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee uh Charlie
McIntyre Lottery director I want to
thank the folks from LBA for their
efforts and their industry in this area
obviously an important function that we
are audited annually uh with me is our
chief compliance officer and in
his way is making sure of compliance I'd
like to note that the clock in the
fiscal committee room hasn't been
adjusted for dead savings time and still
ref 11:17 so I think the fiscal
committee should be in compliance with
the we're not perfect
either uh with that Mr chair members of
the committee I would happy to answer
questions or uh our CFO our chief
compliance officer ask Senator Ros thank
you Mr chairman if I look at page
four um at the top
am I correct in understanding that we
may have undercollected $3 million
between last year and this year on
historic horse racing and is there um a
possibility of
recouping those funds oh thank you for
the question uh Senator uh I don't
believe that that um observation is
indicating that that is uh an amount
that is undercollected
um so just to clarify the current
process or the process as it was audited
um game operators are uh able to reduce
uh their tax liability uh through free
play uh through offering free play
there's a up to a 15% discount um that
could be um could be taken out of their
taxable uh Revenue um the commission at
the time of the audit was monitoring
that through periodic audits as we do
with um all other forms of gaming um and
as uh LBA pointed out uh we also look at
Daily reporting with respect to Historic
horse racing um and we um but but those
daily reports don't include the free
play so we had only been doing that
review periodically the periodic reviews
that we had done had uh tied out uh and
not had any concern about the amount of
free play that was actually being
um being identified we haven't had an
audit observation that recognizes that
um I believe what LBA is looking for
though is make sure that we actually
strengthen that even more to ensure that
we're doing that and in fact we are
doing that now as a monthly desk audit
um but to to uh your your your general
question Senator we don't see any
evidence that they were actually uh
under payment of historic horse racing
revenues to the
state
representative Earth for a
motion move to accept place on file and
release of the public in the usual
manner second motion and second any
further discussion seeing none you're
ready for the question all in favor say
I I those no um than chairman
congratulations I know you get audited
every year I guess the newest game is
the only one that had a few blips in it
because the rest of it is running
smoothly I will see to it that um at
least no later than the next budget that
this amount of transfer money is
adjusted that dollar figure goes back to
I think 2008 when we were doing $120
million in sales and this year we do 320
million and so it's you know it's we're
selling too many tickets we wait to see
your recommendation for the figure
appreciate that Mr chairman thank you we
make sure it's it's in the
budget thank
you
thank you
Jean
okay we have a full house here the last
presentation today is the U management
letter of uh The Liquor Commission uh
with me to present the report is Jim lar
Rivier he's a sen senior manager in our
office and he was in charge of
conducting this audit and joining us
from The Liquor Commission is uh the
chairman Joe m M um Chief Financial
Officer Tina demur and Chief Operating
Officer James Farah and uh now I'll turn
it over to Jim for the
presentation morning chairman wer and
members of the committee again for the
record my name is Jim larier I'm here to
present the uh New Hampshire Liquor
commission's fiscal year 2023 management
letter if you turn to the table of
contents you can see the report contains
five internal control
comments no material weaknesses were
identified and the commission concurred
with all of the
observations no comment suggests that
legislative action may be
required the observations begin on page
three observation number one discusses
the ongoing risks posed while the
commission continues to use its
36-year-old information system mapper
while it
while it's implementing its new system
nextg due to lack of effective system
controls an incident occurred in March
of
2023 whereby unintentional changes were
made to the mapper data table that
resulted in off- premise
licensees receiving a greater discount
than they were entitled to receive the
commission reports that the overapplied
discounts affected 26 entities totaling
$878,000
the commission intend to recoup the Lost
sales but as of the end of our audit
still had neither notified nor build the
affected
entities we recommend the commission
consider and respond to risk posed by
the lack of sufficient controls over
data Integrity in its mapper system
ensure its nextg system has appropriate
controls in place to ensure data
Integrity such as edit checks and other
da data validation
procedures the commission should ensure
appropriate controls are developed and
programming changes made to the nextg
system timely notify and Bill off-
premise licenses that receive the
incorrect
discount turning to page four
observation number two notes
$266,000 of equipment purchased in
2017 was never received and was not
discovered as missing until fiscal year
2023 when the equipment was needed for
the implementation of the nextg
system the missing items were believed
to have been included on a shrink wrap
pallet with other equipment and were
purchased from a former vendor with whom
the commission no longer has
recourse the items weren't detected as
missing during the commission's annual
physical inventory
procedures we recommend the commission
strengthen its controls over the receipt
and payment of goods by establishing
policies and proc
procedures ensuring that all items
received are physically inspected upon
receipt and are properly accounted for
ensuring staff involved are familiar
with the payment requirements and
ensuring that all equipment items of
$250 or more are properly identified
tagged and recorded on the commission's
equipment listing in accordance with
State
policy
Additionally the commission should
perform a thorough physical inventory of
equipment annually and investigate and
resolve differences between physical
items and the commission's records on a
time in a timely
manner observation number three
beginning on page six we recommend the
commission estabish establish formal
policies and procedures for the request
input review and approval of product
price changes and depletion allowances
that require a commission match we
recommend the commission review periodic
reports of product price changes and
depletion allowance offers that require
a match to ensure that they were
formally approved by the Commissioners
and design formal procedures for the
authorization and approval of product
price changes and depletion allowance
allowances matches that could be
incorporated into the nextg system
process upon
implementation
our last two observations number four
and five begin on page seven observation
number four recommends the commission
develop a disaster recovery plan which
should be periodically tested reviewed
and updated as needed and the commission
should continue to establish a formal
risk assessment process and observation
number five on page nine recommends the
Commission in coordination with the
Department of Information Technology
adhere to the state wide information
security manual and test its system
backup processes at least
annually the current status of Prior
audit findings for fiscal years 2022 and
2021 begins on page 11 located behind
the tab of the combined five comments
contained in those reports two are fully
resolved and three are still in the
process of being
remediated this concludes my
presentation I'd like to thank the
Lottery Commission for their assistance
and cooperation throughout the audit and
with your permission chairman well I'd
like to turn the presentation over to
Chairman mikica for any comments he may
have commission welcome thank you very
much Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record Joseph
mikica chairman of the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission and you know Tina
demir's our CFO and James V our coo like
to thank Christine Jim and and Jean as
you know we get audited every year and
we take our audit observations seriously
and always take responsibility for the
findings and we address observation and
answer questions before that we need to
point out that three of the five
observations are it resource related
I've discussed this with commissioner
gluay and we're moving forward in a
different direction with our it in the
future observation number one the first
observation as a result of human error
due to the 36y old system with limited
it resources to maintain the system and
migrate to the nextg system the two main
employees with institutional knowledge
of this system are retirees that come
into the office part-time and let me
just state that we have been blessed to
have these two employees come these two
gentlemen come in and assist us during
this massive transition there's very
little embedded information
other than what these two individuals
have um over a 40-year period this
system probably should have been
upgraded four times and it wasn't as
noted in the observation in 2022 there
is an inherent risk in running the
Legacy system with riing on retired
staff
resources we raid the risks of
continuing operations with the current
system and the risk of deploying the new
system before it was ready before we
considered it was ready implementing the
nextg system before was ready would have
put hundreds of millions of dollars at
risk unfortunately one of these
gentlemen made a mistake and this is the
result the good news is that the go live
date for the next gen system is in two
weeks and will take place on April 1st
everything is being transitioned now
from the new system to the old system
the data is being loaded into the new
system so April 1st we're ready to go
we'd like to put on the record that this
discovery was internally corrected and
self-reported to the LBA by the
nhlc we have not notified or invoiced
the lies for several reasons first we
wanted to make ensure that the invoicing
was correct which is a huge undertaking
because it took place in two different
years because the data mining involved
in the old system is again back to
limited resources and especially
difficult while you're trying to
implement a new system so you say why
was it so difficult well there's power
buys to be involved one-time buys sale
pricing post off broker discounts
monthly sales all have to be taken into
consideration go back and make sure that
we're charging these lenses the correct
amount for everything that they bought
over that period of time each product
and transition had to be fully vetted to
ensure proper price pricing and
accuracy and that has been done secondly
we wanted to wait until this audit was
complete and give the committ committee
the opportunity to weigh in as
businessmen and women our opinion is
that we should invoice the lenses for
the outstanding funds owed to the state
apologize for any inconvenience to them
and move forward that's what business
people
do uh Tina can walk you through at this
point how who is affected and H how many
it's affected and to what dollar amount
if you'd like to do that and then I'd
like to go on to Observation two what
percentage this these uh losses what
percentage of your total do they
represent like 1% or something oh a lot
less than that you you're looking at um
like half a percent so it for our uh
5,000 licenses that we have this
impacted 359 licenses in FY 23 it was
322 for a little over 400,000 and in FY
24 it was 46 for about 470,000
thank you thank you Mr chairman so in
observation number two was an uh the
result of an the it lead at the time who
was no longer at the commission signed
off on a receipt of a bundle of
equipment and approved payment to our I
to our project manager without
verification when the equipment was
received it was palletized and stored in
the warehouse and not discovered of the
shortage until it was taken down to be
deployed as part of the new system after
this discovery of a was made a full
inventory was done and it was determined
that this was an isolated incident it
did not it did not involve any alcohol
at all and significantly we have now
formed a formal process in place for
packages coming into the HQ and all of
the
nhlc and observation number five uh we
rely on our embedded IT staff to provide
us guidance for the necessary it related
policies we have started conversations
on the next step and are moving forward
with those policies in order to comply
with this
finding and we'd be happy to answer any
questions that anyone may have thank you
Mr chairman congratulations you're very
thorough as is Mr lovier especially as
you you get audited every year and he
quite often does some of them so it's
it's a uh a nitpicking process at best
when you have to come back every year so
congratulations thank you Mr chairman
representative ER for for
motion move to accept place on file and
Rel leas of the public in the usual
manner second motion and a second all in
favor say I I I'll I'll oppose no and
any further discussion any further
questions
congratulations appreciate your good
work and especially I'm impressed with
the fact that you found the era rather
than waiting for Mr La Riviera who never
overlooks anything thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you very
much thank
you
all
right there's nothing further to come
before us we've discussed the final date
anything else anybody wants from the
legislative budget
assistant thank you all the chair taking
action on the clock or since it's his
room just a little humor appreciate it I
will try to do something about it we are
adjourned
e